How's you know,
Freud believed that a substantial
proportion of the symptoms he saw among
his clients were of psychological
origin,
despite the fact that some of them are
manifest physically.
Uh,
these things do happen by the way.
I had a client who was from eastern
Europe from eastern and Eastern European
background,
which is relevant in that I believe her
upbringing to be more similar to the
kind of upbringing that the victorians
that Freud studied were then say more
the people of people in the West.
And she had the same thing that her
grandmother had,
which was,
um,
psychosomatic epilepsy.
And so she expressed what we're often
sexual conflicts through epileptic
seizures.
She had an epileptic seizure of this
type in my lab,
my office one day.
And uh,
you know,
she was unsure whether they were real or
not,
but I've seen people have epileptic
seizures.
And as a general rule it's quite
upsetting.
But she had an epileptic seizure in my
office.
And one of the things I noted was that
it didn't really bother me.
And one of the things I've noticed about
being a therapist is if someone is,
is manifesting a lot of emotion and a,
it's not bothering me,
then it's a good hint that there's
something wrong,
that it's not real.
There's something about it that isn't
exactly right because it doesn't seem to
hook in your MPA empathic systems the
same way.
So,
um,
I had another client.
This has actually happened to two of my
clients.
The first one was attacked by her
boyfriend and she was unbelievably
naive.
She was so naive.
You like,
you could write a whole book about how
naive she was.
I'm serious.
It was unbelievable.
Her parents actually taught her.
This is the literal truth.
Her parents taught her that adults were
angels.
It's not a good way of preparing your
child for the grown up world.
Anyways,
she'd had a fight with her boyfriend and
he attacked her with sexual intent.
And when we went through this and it was
under hypnosis,
she described his face.
She said he had a look of sheer
malevolence,
right?
He,
she'd never seen that.
She was like a 28 year old woman.
She was a,
she had a,
she had an undergraduate degree,
she was no idiot.
Um,
I asked her like,
how can you reconcile your belief that
adults were angels with all the things
that you learned about history and your
undergraduate degree?
And she basically said,
well,
I just put those things in a compartment
and didn't pay any attention to them.
It's like,
yeah,
okay.
So she saw this guy's face when he was
intending harm and it was actually the
look on his face that traumatized her
and it traumatized her so badly that she
had severe psychosomatic symptoms severe
enough to get her diagnosed as
schizophrenia for five years nonstop at
night for four hours at a time.
And the symptoms were that her whole
body would shake and she would be unable
to sleep.
So.
And I had another client who had the
same thing,
not the same thing,
but a similar thing happened to her in
high school where a boy was picking on
her continually with malevolent intent.
And the thing that really made that
memory stick in her face was the look of
malevolence on his face.
So.
So you see some people are definitely
capable of some behavior that is most
properly explained as far as I can tell
in terms that are similar to Freud's,
what's repressed,
unbearable memories,
often sexual and impermissible desires.
How do you defend against things that
you don't want to be true?
While there's repression,
Freud really thought that was
unconscious.
People didn't know they were repressing.
So I sent you guys a link you may have
noticed about the Gottman studies on
married couples.
I think there are still.
Studies are bloody brilliant,
you know,
and what Godman found in exactly typical
is that the couples who are going to get
divorced when you see them in their
natural habitat,
they're all nice to each other,
but they're psychophysiological systems
are just going preserved there like prey
and Predator to each other.
You know,
and you know,
I don't know if that's repression or if
it's suppression.
These things are very difficult to
distinguish because they're not that
well defined but.
But there is a lot of activity beneath
the surface,
that's for sure.
And the problem with being
psychophysiology logically aroused like
that is that the consequences of that
overtime is physical,
right?
Because what's happens when you're
aroused like that as you produce a lot
of the stress hormone cortisol and that
activates the general stress response.
And the General Stress Response
Basically Robs your future stores of
energy and ability to overreact in the
present.
And if you do that long enough,
well you'll damage your brain.
That's one of the things that happens.
But there's many other things that
happened too.
So denial people will just say,
well,
that's not so bad,
or maybe that's normal.
We'll see a lot of that when I show you
this movie reaction formation,
which is,
it's like,
it's,
it's overcompensation in some sense.
So maybe you really hate your sister and
you buy her a great big Christmas
present,
you know,
because you'd like to think that you
like,
or.
But really you don't like her at all.
Um,
they're often sibling rivalry can be
unbelievably intense.
Um,
displacement.
This is a good one.
My boss yells at me,
I yell at my husband,
my husband yells at the baby,
the baby bites the cat,
you know,
so it's a cascading chain of,
of emotion.
Often I find with people though that if
they come home and they're in a bad mood
and they're touchy,
you know,
and,
and you,
you say something to them and you know,
they,
they fly off the handle.
It isn't exactly so much that they've
suppressed or repressed or denied what's
happening at work.
At least not in any obvious sense.
Not that day.
Often you have to like prior around in
the person and talk to them and harass
them a bit until they,
you know,
often tell emotion arises,
which is partly why Freud thought about
his transformation processes Cathartic.
And then they figure out.
They'll cry and say,
well,
I'm really upset at my boss.
And the.
It's not obvious that the person
actually knew that when they came home
and like the unconscious issue is quite
a difficult one to,
to tear apart.
My conclusion has been that when people
that repression isn't really much
different than lying except that
the lie is initially conscious when you
first make,
but if you keep habitually lying about
something,
you develop a little automated circuit
that either does the lying or that has
the replacement story at hand and after
200 repetitions at the same damn lie,
you've built a little machine in your
head that handles all that and at that
point it can be unconscious because you
don't need it.
You don't need to be conscious to make
that decision anymore.
So if you practice something deceptive
long enough,
I think it becomes habitual and
unconscious.
So I would recommend that you don't do
that unless you want your head full of
little pathological monsters that you
can't control.
I mean,
maybe it's already like that.
That would be a freudian idea.
Identification is another defense
mechanism.
You're bullied.
You want to become the bully
rationalization.
That's when you don't actually.
This is.
This is the thing that people who are
highly intelligent,
they're really good at,
you know they've got a problem and they
come up with some perfectly coherent and
reasonable explanation for the problem
or the misbehavior.
That has absolutely nothing to do with
what's actually going on.
And if you.
If you marry someone,
for example,
who's more introverted than you or less
verbally fluent,
this is something to really watch out
for it because just because you could
win an argument with someone doesn't
mean you're right and if you're verbally
fluent and extroverted,
you can often tie people up in knots.
But I would say beware of that because
just because the person you're arguing
with can't formulate their ideas as fast
as you and just because they may not be
able to hold their own in an argument
with you.
That does not mean they don't know what
they see.
And if you have any intelligence and
you're married to someone like that,
you actually try to coax what they think
out of them and help them articulate it
and formulate it.
Because there's always the possibility
that you're doing something underhanded
and sneaky and dangerous in the medium
to longterm,
and it might be better for both of you
if you figured it out intellectually
ization.
Well,
if you've ever watched a woody allen
movie,
you know what that is,
um,
what are,
y'all should have had union
psychotherapy,
not Freud in psychotherapy because he's
a creative person.
And one of the things I've noticed is
that I have clients who are very
creative and other clients who aren't as
creative and the ones who were creative
spontaneously manifest processes in
their dreams that are most easily
interpreted in union form.
It doesn't seem to be the case for
people that weren't creative though.
And if I talk to them about mythological
or symbol like ideas,
it doesn't click for them.
So what we usually do things that are
much more practical.
What much more like behavior therapy
projection is a good one.
I'm not irritated.
Your irritating,
you know,
and it's,
it's,
it's a toss up often because,
you know,
you might think,
well,
no one can irritate you without your
permission.
It's like,
believe me,
if you think that you've not been around
some world class irritating people
because there are certainly people,
borderline personalities are like that,
who I don't care if you're a safe man,
sooner or later you're going to get
irritated because that's actually the
goal of the behavior in large part.
So
Freud's fundamental theory was that
unconscious ideas were at the core of
many psychological conflicts like
incomprehensible distress.
Psychosomatic symptoms are
psychosomatic.
Cyst is when your body attempts to
represent something that you're
repressing.
Now.
I think there's two ways of looking at
that because I don't actually think.
I don't always think that's what
happens.
I think sometimes the reaction to the
situation in question is actually
sematic to begin with,
and then if it's articulated and worked
out,
the body can can.
It's like the memory locale shifts or
the representation area shifts.
So for example,
I had a client,
she had a wonderful time.
She,
she got fired from her job and they
bundled her into her car and it was
sudden she didn't see it coming and then
on the way home her car was hit by
another car.
So like that was a perfect way to be
traumatized because she was already
really upset and on edge obviously,
and then this car hit her at about 50
miles an hour and it hurt her quite
badly and she had minimal brain injury,
which is a really rough one because it
has non specific symptoms and like she,
she,
she'd come to therapy and I,
I talked to her for her ideas were quite
fragmented so it took us quite a long
time to kind of weave a coherent story
together.
But she'd sit there like this,
you know,
and one of the things that I found after
a while when I was working with her was
that I was really uncomfortable watching
her and it was a discomfort that seemed
to center about here.
It was a physiological response,
probably a mirroring response.
And one day I said to her,
it was like a spontaneous impulse.
I said,
come over.
We'd worked together for a long time.
By the time said,
look,
come over here.
I'm leaning on the desk.
So I had her lean on the desk and then I
sort of pounded on her shoulders down
down her spine and she started to cry
and she cried like for 45 minutes and
then that loosened up a shoulder and
then we.
Another thing we did was to.
I had her,
she said she couldn't lift her arm a.
So we were doing basically exposure.
I said,
okay,
lift your arm and then let it go and
then lift your arm another inch and let
it go and then lift your arm another
inch and let it go.
And soon we had her arm up like this.
She had moved her arm above her head in
like five years because she was in this
like protective crouch.
It's like a startle response and I think
that if you're traumatized,
often what happens is your body throws
itself into a state of hyper preparation
and then unless you can,
unless you can bring the meaning of the
traumatic event up and articulate it and
throw away what it isn't,
you know,
like.
Because when she got hit by the car and
lost her job,
part of her idea was,
well,
my life is over now,
you know,
because you can understand why someone
would think that.
So I would say,
well,
yes,
that's understandable,
but it's too global and vague
formulation to be helpful,
but if your life is over and there's
nothing you can do,
this is probably the right thing to do.
You know?
And so sometimes it's not so much that
the simplest sematic symptoms are a
consequence of repression and then
symbolic,
symbolic representation,
it's that the actual response to the
event starts out physiological and it
never gets any farther than that.
And so partly what you're doing is,
and I think it's,
it's like a permanent manifestation of
the stress response.
So he thought of behavior anomalies in
this way and hallucinations and
delusions.
Like a lot of this stuff is dead on as
far as I'm concerned.
Like you see this,
you see this a lot with people that you
have an intimate relationship with.
You know,
like there's something off about what
they're doing.
Well,
for example,
in the gottman study,
that's a good example.
You know how Gottman said I'm the
successful couples have responded to
each other's bids,
right?
So if,
if you're in the house and your,
your wife says,
um,
oh look,
there's a,
there's a cardinal in the backyard and
it's really pretty,
you know what that means is maybe you
could come over here and look at this
bird with me and you know,
that would help me understand that you
liked me and they're interested in what
I'm doing,
you know.
And so you can say in Gottman's terms,
you can just say,
I don't want to look at your stupid
bird.
That's not a great response.
Or you can say really,
okay,
you put down your newspaper,
whatever it is and look like you're
really perturbed and then you walk over
there and no,
that's a good response to because then
you can also destroy her pleasure and
looking at the bird.
So without really looking like a son of
a bitch.
So that's a good one.
Or you can just sort of see.
I love that one.
Which means,
oh,
you're annoying.
I'm so put upon,
I really,
you're always asking me to do stupid
things and I'm so generous and giving
and here you are exploiting me again and
then you go over and you look at the
burden,
you know,
maybe a smile with your mouth but not
your eyes and that's real nice.
And then the other one is,
well you go over there like civilized
human being,
like interacting with someone that you'd
actually like to get along with for the
next 30 years.
But the things in all those other three
categories,
those are,
there is like just in that Psi,
there's a whole bloody massive snakes
underneath it.
You know.
And if you,
if you watch someone who does that and
you go after them,
you know,
if you decide you're going to solve
this,
you have to dig down into that side.
Like God only knows how deep it might be
a decade old,
you know,
they're harboring some bloody resentment
that occurred like 15 years ago is those
things are just stacked up like,
like little bombs underneath the surface
of this little tiny behavioral auction.
You know?
And usually people will just ignore it,
which is not a good idea,
but because they're conflict avoidant,
people are very,
very conflict avoidant and they like to
think that,
well,
if everything's just all right right
now,
it'll stay all right into the future.
It's like,
no,
it won't,
it absolutely will not.
And if you don't deal with little
things,
then all the monsters that are packed up
inside the will eventually eat you.
So,
but that's a while in the future.
So you don't really have to worry about
it.
It's not a very good,
a good way of thinking about things.
Freud also noticed,
noticed that people make jokes about
things that are often repressed.
And that's definitely the case if you
watch a good comedian,
especially the ones that are a little
bit more on the outrageous side,
what they're doing constantly is saying
things that people don't want to believe
but know are true.
And so they'll reveal something that
everybody knows and everybody will laugh
because yeah,
we know that.
But you're not supposed to say it.
And um,
what's his name?
The Indian comic from.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's the guy.
I mean,
he's always making racial jokes,
right?
So funny because it's,
this whole audience is full of,
it's really,
really racially and ethnically mixed
mixed audience and all he does is pick
out people in like assault them for
their race or ethnic identity and
they're all laughing way like,
oh,
it's so cute that we're all in here like
insulting each other and,
but you know,
he's,
he's giving voice to,
um,
what to commonly held stereotypes that
no one will admit to holding or knowing.
And so it's kind of a relief to everyone
to have that broad out in the open,
in some safe place.
So slips of the tongue are also an
interesting phenomena.
You can watch people very carefully for
this because now and then they'll say
something that means something other
than what they thought it would say,
or it means something contrary or it's a
hint into one of these like stacks of
monsters that normally they didn't want
to admit to and you have to be sharp to,
to catch these things.
You have to pay real attention.
You can also see the same thing with
micro-expressions,
often with people that's given rise to
this whole new politically correct
movement about suppressing
microaggression,
which is like one of the most
pathological things I've ever heard of,
you know,
like getting rid of your micro
aggression expressions that does not
make you a good person just makes you a
trickier sort of psychopath.
So Freud also was extremely interested
in dreams and his theory was that a
dream was a wish fulfillment and like I
really don't think that's a good theory.
I think that sometimes some dreams have
a wish like element,
although I should say,
even though I'm not very fond of the
wish fulfillment theory,
I don't think it's comprehensive enough.
His,
the other things he had to say about
dreams were absolutely brilliant.
So the,
his book,
if you want to read one book by Freud,
I would say the book on dreams is the
best and unfortunately at the moment I
can't remember what it's called,
the interpretation of dreams,
right?
It's a very thick book and you know,
it can't boil down Freud's theory of
dreams.
It's a whole book into one phrase,
wish,
fulfillment,
you know he's way smarter than that and
so you,
you don't,
for each writing is sort of like
fiction.
You can't condense it.
You have to read it.
So you know,
sometimes it seems obvious like if the
dream is of a sexual nature,
you can easily see whether that might be
a,
you know,
a wish fulfillment or something like
that.
In hungry people will dream about food.
So it's not the case that and lonely
people will dream about social comfort
and so forth.
So it's not the case precisely that the
dream can't have anything to do with
wishes.
Jung's idea,
which I think is a better idea and I
think it's more grounded in how we
understand dreams in the modern world,
was that the dream was compensate Tory
so that if you're,
if you had a particularly rigid
viewpoint and in of the world and that
rigid viewpoint was actually impeding
your progress forward,
that the dream would spin up counter
propositional fantasies in an attempt to
update the,
the,
the stiffening in the and the rigidity
of the more explicit belief system.
And
I think there's some good evidence for
that in modern studies of dreaming it
seems.
It's certainly the case that dreams do
seem to update your memory and our eyes.
I think partly what the dreams are doing
too,
and this is maybe where some of the
symbolic content comes from,
is there's this,
you know,
it's not obvious how you should
structure a category,
right?
Because categories,
they're very fluid,
you know,
you might think,
well all men is a good category,
you know,
and then you might think,
well all white men and old non white men
is a good category depending on what
you're discussing and so on,
you know,
the contents of your categories often
depend on what you want to do with the
category.
So it's not obvious what should be in
the box and what should it be.
And partly what the dream is doing too,
is by loosening up the categorical
structure,
you know,
because things can fluidly change and
transform and dreams.
And it allows you to experiment with re
categorization while you're asleep,
without having to suffer the
consequences of that in the waking world
because you're paralyzed right?
So I think it's more accurate to think
of the dream as an,
as part of the process by which new
knowledge becomes eventually articulated
and that's more of a union perspective.
So you start out not knowing anything
about it and then maybe you can code it
onto your behavior.
That would be something piaget would
suggest.
And then after it's coated onto
behavior,
maybe you can start expressing it in
image,
especially in dynamic images.
And so that would be something like
fiction and so you can think of dreams
as a kind of fiction and then once
you've got the thing laid out in
fiction,
especially if it's kind of coherent,
then it's not a huge leap from that to
having an articulated model.
And I think a lot of what you're doing
when you do dream interpretation in
psychotherapy is you're doing the same
thing that you would do if you were
interpreting literature.
Um,
and you know,
you think,
well,
is it worthwhile thinking about
literature?
It's like,
well,
you know,
it's worthwhile reading it.
Fine.
Is it worthwhile thinking about what
you're reading?
It's different process.
It's like arguably,
well,
so the dream has a function and it does
whatever dreams do and then perhaps
there's also some utility in attending
to the dream consciously and trying to
elaborate upon its contents.
And Freud would do that with Free
Association and works.
It really works.
It's quite fun.
If you have someone who's a good
dreamer,
you know,
you say,
okay,
they,
the way I do it as they are,
they tell me the dream,
they read it and I listened to it and I
let my imagination work on it.
So it kind of builds up an association
net and then I have them start from the
beginning again and whenever they come
to a theme or an object or something
like that that's identifiable,
then I asked them what that reminds them
up and so to me what we're doing is
flushing out the association network and
that's a freudian idea.
And then if you walk through the whole
dream like and then people will
associate and then that will remind them
of something and then maybe they'll
remember why a specific date is in the
dream or something like that.
And so it's like the dream is putting
together ideas that have a vague cloud
around them and it's trying to sequence
and organize them and you seem to be
able to facilitate that process with
conscious reflection.
So,
and for some people it's extremely
useful.
I mean,
one of the things young said,
which I really liked was that if you're
stuck in a problem and you can't solve
it,
you have no idea how to solve a terrible
conflict of some sort.
You have to look where you don't know.
And he thought,
well,
one of the places that you don't know is
in your dreams and you think,
well,
dreams are doing something and there's
good evidence that part of what dreams
are doing is dealing with novel
information.
You know,
they're trying to conceptualize novel
information.
And so that's a good place to look for
new potential solutions because you can
also think of the dream as part of a
hypothesis generating mechanism that
would also be the creative imagination.
So
I think often the reason,
I think maybe the reason that sometimes
people remember dreams that are
extremely emotional and they feel
compelled to tell them is perhaps is
because the people who did that,
I think about it from an evolutionary
perspective.
The people who did that and expose the
fantasy to the group,
we're more likely to gather information
about what it meant and possibly more
likely to survive.
And so there seems to be a trigger
level,
you know,
above which the dream is specifically
particularly sufficiently emotionally
impactful.
So the actually remember when you wake
up and you would also often consider
those big dreams,
you know,
especially if they had archetipal
content and those would also sometimes
be dreams that had relevance beyond the
relevance to the specific individual.
So they might be dreams that are working
really hard on a problem that's
collective.
So,
and you know,
you think,
well,
where do new ideas come from?
You know,
well they just appeared in my head.
It's like that's not a very good theory.
You know,
the idea has a birthplace,
the birthplace is in the unknown.
And then there's a tremendous amount of
elaboration of that information before
it ever gets up to where it pops into
your head is an articulated statement,
you know,
that's not a,
that's not an instantaneous magical
transformation or maybe you can think it
is,
but it's,
you know,
it's not a very useful theory.
And the idea that there are multiple
stages of processing of information each
with their own natures much more in
keeping with the way that modern people
look at the brain,
which is as a Oregon that's evolved,
that has very,
very archaic elements like massively
archaic,
like the ones I told you about that were
you share it with lobsters and then
there's all sorts of weird systems built
on top of that that are basically there
for biological purposes.
And then there's a cortical cap that
sort of elaborates and all those things
are working together to extract out
information that you can use for living.
It's certainly not mechanical.
It's not exactly computational.
It's,
it's a multistage process.
And dreams and imagination are involved
at least at the hypothesis stage.
So.
So you can think of dream as a
hypothesis in some sense,
and although I don't think,
I don't think it's reasonable to say
that dreams do one thing anymore than it
is reasonable to say that thinking does
one thing,
but the competence Satori idea is a good
one and you can kind of think of the
wish fulfillment ideas,
that subset of that.
So the dream is also,
Freud says that process of regression
that manifests itself simultaneously in
three fashions as topical regression
from the conscious to the unconscious as
temporal regression from the present
time to childhood.
Sometimes you see this with people
who've had repetitive nightmares.
One thing I can tell you,
you can try this.
If you have a repetitive nightmare,
usually it presents the same thematic
problem over and over.
Like maybe you're being chased by a
monster when you turn around.
Um,
maybe your hands are tied or something
like that.
You know,
which,
if you told me about that,
I think,
well,
who or what is tying your hands?
Right?
That would be the first question,
but one of the things you can do to make
that nightmare go away is to sit down,
reimagine the nightmare,
and fix the ending.
Now you have to come up with a
reasonable ending.
So for example,
I had a client who was afraid.
She had a cabin,
was very interesting case.
She had a mouse phobia and she was
afraid mice would run up her leg.
That was the specific content of the
phobia and she had a cabin and she
didn't like to go to the cabin for two
reasons.
One was a mouse might run up her leg and
the second was she was up there alone
and she was afraid that she would get
attacked and sexually assaulted.
So it doesn't take much of a frailty and
genius to figure out the connection
between those two things.
But one of the things we did was first
of all talk it through as if it was a
reasonable fear.
It's like,
well,
you are up there alone.
Maybe you could have an alarm system and
some good locks.
It's like,
you know,
so your fear might be predicated on some
realistic,
some realistic appraisal which you're
repressing,
you're not dealing with it.
It is potentially dangerous fix that.
Get a dog,
you know,
so we did all that and simultaneously
treated or most phobia through
behavioral exposure and then she was
having these dreams of these guys
breaking in and raping her and so we had
her walk through,
I think she bought a bat and put it by
her bed,
which was something I suggested.
And then we walked her through.
I walked her through the dream and we
changed the ending.
So what she did was the guy climbed in
the window and she picked up the bat and
she smacked him one and then she sprayed
him with oven cleaner,
which is like a really nasty thing to
do.
Then she tied him up in a chair and she
was like,
she was dancing around in the office
thinking that's,
you know,
that's a hero myth essentially.
Right?
We changed,
we transformed the dream from victim to
hero essentially.
And that was the end of her nightmares.
And that happens more often than you
than you might think because the dream
is presenting you with the problem,
right?
It's like a threat detection mechanism.
It says,
well here's the threat.
Maybe it's expressing it in symbolic
terms or maybe it's using a general
category like monster.
It's like our monsters chasing you.
Well,
it depends on what you mean by monsters.
But functionally,
yes they are,
you know,
while you might think,
well,
conceptualizing them as monsters isn't
exactly accurate.
It's like,
well,
it's not exactly clear that it's not
accurate.
So
I think a monster is a monster is like a
representation of the class of all
things that could chase you and devour
you.
And there's lots of those that are
symbolic and articulate.
Like if you're arguing with someone who
can defeat you or you know,
there are,
there are certainly predators on the,
on the Internet that are waiting for you
at pretty much any moment to slip up.
And like the idea that the world is full
of monstrous embodied forces that have
you as target for pray.
It's like,
yes,
that's right.
Obviously that's right.
So,
so Freud,
Freud's theory of dreams was essentially
that there was a little late and content
in the dream,
which is what the dream really meant,
and then the layers of weird
transformation of the idea.
He thought about displacement where one
thing would stand for another or
condensation where a lot of the events
would be rammed together in a very short
sequence or symbolization.
So like the mouse in my client's phobia
would be a good example of
symbolization,
of fear,
of sexual penetration and dramatization.
He thought of those is all ways that the
dream was hiding the latent content from
the dreamer in order to protect sleep.
Whereas you young and Freud really
argued about this and it's part of what
broke them apart.
Young said,
no,
that's,
that might be right in some cases,
but generally what the dream is doing,
it's just a fact of nature.
The dream is trying to think something
up and so it might be concentrating on
something that you refuse to admit to
and repressed,
but sometimes it's just like out there
with free play at fantasy,
trying to generally orient you in the
world.
So he thought about it and you'll also
thought it's like young was an
archeologist of the Ed in some sense,
you know,
he thought of the Ed as a much as a more
creative place in some sense than than
Freud did and as the place where new
ideas and new adaptive patterns were
born.
So he believed that the dream was
generally fairly logical and one of the
things you did when you recounted the
dream,
no matter how accurately you tried to
recount it,
was to transform it into more of a
narrative form than it actually took as
a dream.
And so no doubt that's true because when
you describe an experience,
even if it's an experience you have
every day,
you basically extract out the gist and
then describe the.
And you have to do the same thing with
dreams because you can't present the
images.
So it might that just the act of telling
the dream might even be useful in that
sense.
Because what you're doing is making
whatever that thought is more coherent
than it would otherwise be.
So.
So I want to run through this,
this psychosexual theory very rapidly,
and then I want to show you some
examples of it so you don't believe that
in some sense,
you know you had a primary energy and
that psychic energy,
that's what we call energy.
You know,
when you say I'm feeling energetic
today,
it's not obvious what that means,
but Freud regarded that as libidinal and
he thought that there were multiple
sources of libido,
but the most fundamental source with
sexuality,
and I think he thought that in part
because of the influence of Darwin's
ideas,
because Darwin basically said that the
goal of organisms was essentially to
procreate.
The sexual urge is extraordinarily
strong and so he thought it was primary
and you can make a reasonable case that
it's primary,
but I think it's too reductionistic
because there's lots of drives that
people have and it isn't obvious that
they all coagulate into a single source
of energy.
Somewhere in the psyche.
If you look at the way the brain is
structured,
actually the part of the brain that
wakes you up,
it's called the reticular activating
system and it's.
It's,
it's some strands way down in the brain
stem that,
that,
that branch out in a Mo in many,
many ways out into the brain like a tree
in some sense,
if you twist your head the wrong way
when you have a car accident,
sometimes you can shear off those tracks
and then you're in a coma and there's
nothing that can be done about it,
but the reticular activating system is
really,
really old.
I could seems older than all the
motivation and emotional systems,
and so if there is a libido,
which would be whatever it is that the
reticular activating system does in
order to awaken you from your slumber,
say,
or to put you on alert when something
happens,
it looks like it's older than all the.
The isolated,
motivational and emotional systems.
So the libido per se,
isn't sexual by,
by all appearances.
It's something that's below sexuality.
No.
So,
but you know,
it's still reasonable to note that
sexuality is a powerful driving force.
So
Freud said it begins its development in
infancy.
The infant is a sexual being by which he
meant the infant is capable of
experiencing sexual pleasure.
So why not,
I should let you know that one of the
practices of Victoria nurses with male
babies was to masturbate them till they
till satiation so they would sleep.
So it's not,
it's there,
it's not like there's no evidence for
sexual pleasure in,
in,
in children,
in infants in particular,
Freud thought about that as
polymorphously,
perverse by which he meant that the
infant was willing to take pleasure in
any,
in any activity whatsoever,
and babies can have some pretty messy
habits without any structuring of that
and then that that channeled in various
ways as the,
as the,
as the baby developed.
So here,
here are his stages,
the aural period.
Well,
it's quite interesting that when a baby
is born,
the part of its body that is in fact
most mature,
most like a mature part in terms of its
eventual function is in fact the mouth
and the tongue and obvious.
There's obvious reasons for that because
the baby has to be able to latch onto
the nipple,
you know right away.
And that's actually quite a complicated
activity.
It's a complicated social activity and
it requires a fair bit of coordination
between the baby and the mother.
It's not something automatic.
So if the baby didn't come out,
um,
you know,
wired up for certain basic in certain
basic ways it wouldn't be able to get
going to begin with.
So it's definitely wired up in an oral
manner.
So he thought if the oral character as
passive optimistic independent,
and there's the anal period where the
Freud thought that's where the ego,
the Super Ego for the first time in some
sense where the child has had to
renounce primary pleasure and so that
would be the pleasure of dedication
fundamentally in favor of a more complex
form of behavior and that that was
actually an inhibitory process and
certainly the case that parents can get
into like year long wars with,
with kids over toilet training,
you know.
So I've seen some pretty weird examples
of that.
So I,
I saw one parent who,
who was in such a war with,
with their three year old,
that that three year old would only
dedicate if the mother put a diaper on
them.
So it had perfect control,
but it was like there was a war going
on,
so,
and he thought of anal people as
orderly,
parsimonious,
and obstinate.
It's kind of interesting too,
because one of the things that we found
recently is that conscientiousness is
one of the big five traits,
right?
You can break it into orderliness and
into industriousness and orderliness,
predicts conservatism and predicts
authoritarianism and it's associated
with disgust sensitivity.
So I thought,
Huh,
that's pretty interesting.
You know,
and it's also the other thing that's
really cool about orderliness and
disgust sensitivity is that it is
associated with disgust associated with
anything that would contaminate.
And so the idea that that's associated
in some sense with,
with,
with anal thinking is
it's,
there's something about it that's right.
You know,
and it's also pretty important to note
that the reason that all you people are
going to live to be 90 or thereabouts,
roughly speaking,
isn't doctors and it's plumbers.
So.
Right.
Really?
So,
you know,
uh,
the,
the life is in itself contaminating and
we have a built in system that's the
disgust system to take care of that
problem.
And it's clear that that does vary in
strength between individuals and it's
also clear that the degree to which that
if you have a stronger disgust system,
you're much more likely to be
conservative in your political beliefs.
So that's pretty cool.
It's like it's not something obvious.
You know,
the Phallic period,
three to five,
that's when Freud believed that children
often discovered masturbation and that's
when girls develop penis envy and boys
develop castration anxiety,
which I said is a small price to pay for
the possession of a penis.
Yeah.
So all right,
here's a way of thinking about the
depaul phase.
It's basically hostility and erotic
attraction towards the parents now for
and thought about this as a normative
part of development.
And
that's a tough one.
It certainly does seem to be the case
and there is some experimental evidence
that boys
fight more with their fathers and girls
fight more with their mothers.
So that's kind of interesting.
But I think I not so sure that the idea
that this is normative development is
exactly right.
And maybe maybe Freud got skewed over a
bit because he was always dealing with
people who had one form of pathology or
another.
Now here's,
here's how to develop an equitable
situation if you want to with your
children.
Some of you will take this road so maybe
this will help you do it better if
that's really what you're into.
So the thing to do is make sure that
your marriage is quite hostile so that
you have a lot of underlying resentment
to your partner and that will,
that will encourage you to suddenly turn
one of your children or more of them
against that parent without them really
knowing it.
And you can do that by covertly
reinforcing them when they do that or
ignoring them,
that's even better when they do the
opposite.
So you know maybe your daughter is being
nice to your husband,
you're already mad at him so that you
know you make it known to her using one
strategy or another that you don't
really approve of that sort of behavior.
So that's pretty effective way of doing
it.
Then the next thing to do is this works
really well.
If you have a young boy and you're a
woman.
It's like you know,
you wanna,
you wanna develop a lot of hostility
towards your husband so you really don't
want to have anything to do with them
and you don't really want him to even
touch you and because of that you're not
even really all that happy about men.
And so then you do two things is that
you turn to your son because he's kind
of harmless and you make your
relationship way closer than it should
be with him and you encourage all sorts
of things that are really kind of on the
edge of acceptable behavior and at the
same time you repress and crush any part
of him that would develop in the kind of
masculinity that would enable him to
turn into the monster that you think
your husband is.
So that's a really effective.
And people can do that for like 20 years
and outcome.
Is that.
I have a lot of business as a therapist
because
I do see this sort of thing and a lot
of.
A lot of what happens in therapy is that
it's an interesting thing is people come
to see me to solve all sorts of
problems,
like have a very large number of sorts,
but one of the common problems is they
cannot get away from their families.
They can't,
they can't break.
Those initial isn't even break them.
The family can't negotiate a to allow
the person to manifest the independence
that would be necessary for them to have
their own life and their own family and
their own career.
And so they're struggling and they're
caught in these often ugly nets,
like often unbelievably ugly nets and
they can't get out of them.
And that's what we're going to see right
now.
So
now this character Robert Crumb,
he's quite the character and we should
turn those lights down.
Yeah,
that's good.
Maybe
we can do a voiceover and this later so
it doesn't really matter if we have.
Let's do that.
Okay.
So Robert Crumb was an underground
cartoonist is an underground cartoonist
and he lived in Berkeley in the late
sixties and this documentary was made
about him and his family and so I'm
going to get you to watch as much of it
as we can watch and maybe I'll show you
a bit more in the next class so I'm not
supposed to because we're supposed to do
something else,
but I might anyways.
Now this film,
I love this film for a variety of
reasons.
First of all,
I think it's a work of genius.
Second,
I've never ever seen any film of any
sort that does as good a job of
illustrating not only what Freudian
psychopathology is and how it manifests
itself symbolically,
but also how the family plays into it.
So away we go
me
off.
Okay.
So here's what happened.
The film crew wants to go to his house
where his brothers still lives and film
his brother Charles,
who's lived there since he was 55 and
he's lived there since he was a
teenager.
And you notice how Robert uses a very
soft voice.
He's talking to his mother and you know,
he's got a whole.
He's a famous guy.
He's got a whole film crew there and
he's basically asking his mother if it's
okay if he brings his friends over and
she basically says,
well,
I don't think that would be such a good
idea,
and he backs off right away.
And then when he gets off the phone he
says,
well,
she said,
no,
you know,
that's it.
So you know,
that's.
That's if you're.
If you have a good snake detector
working and you're listening and
watching closely,
you know that there are a tremendous
number of snakes under the surface
already.
The soul of people
expressing their connection to eternity,
whatever you want to call it,
modern doesn't have lost that.
People can express themselves that way
anymore.
So that's a very paradoxical set of
statements because on the one hand he's
expressing,
he says he really loves old music and he
loves it because he can hear the soul of
the common man being expressed.
But then he takes like a pot shot at the
entire world of music since 1920,
which indicates a tremendous amount of,
of implicit arrogance.
And he also says that's the only time
that he feels any love for humanity.
It's like,
well,
first of all,
I'm not sure that his attitude towards
humanity as a whole is actually all that
relevant.
And second,
if,
if you're,
if you've put yourself in the position
where you regard yourself as a credible
judge of humanity,
it's like you might want to take a few
steps
back from your narcissism,
right?
Right then and there.
So,
and I'm not kidding about this,
I'll tell you,
those kids who showed up at Columbine
high school,
they had their motivations and they
wrote them down and they knew exactly
what they were doing.
And the leader who was the more literary
of the two said quite explicitly that he
was the judge of the human race.
And as far as he was concerned,
it didn't pass his judgment and that you
know,
that he was perfectly reasonable for him
to go on a cleansing binge.
You know?
And,
and he didn't just want to shoot up a
whole,
you know,
a few students in the school,
he had bombs planted all over the
school.
He wanted a whole apocalyptic scene and
they had dreamed about blowing up
Detroit.
And so you could imagine what would
happen if someone like him got their
finger on the button of the,
of the,
of a hydrogen bomb.
So,
you know,
young said,
if you go deep enough into the shadow,
you find hell.
It's like,
that's exactly right.
And it's no joke.
This is mom's house.
Do you read any good books lately?
Just
kind of like recycling a lot of these
books,
recycling.
They've got a very interesting voice
tone,
which,
which you might pick up on as well.
It's very ironic,
like everything they say is ironic.
Scott,
this kind of bitter and arrogant twist
in it and they're talking about
absolutely catastrophic things like
nightmarishly catastrophic things.
Yet there's this sort of adolescent like
banter and,
and laughter about it
when you were reading all year,
20 years ago,
do that
because there's nothing else
you ever read anything new.
Really recent writers
I'm interested in,
most of them
are not nearly as interesting as the old
lady,
so you know,
Freud would say here that there's an
awful lot of intellectual ization going
on and there definitely is.
So these,
these guys are very divorced from their
bodies and they have every reason to be
books.
Charles is the one that started this
whole comic thing.
He was completely obsessed with comics.
We are kids had absolutely no other
normal kid.
Interesting.
Wasn't interested in toys or games in
place.
Scores,
didn't do anything but read comics for
all comics thing.
Come and talk and the drawing,
the other drawing interest besides the
control realistic scenes and you know,
just pictures of buildings and cars and
stuff was interested in that at all.
It's only
the earliest one that is still existed.
I had as Charles through this one that's
supposed to be.
And
Yeah,
so you hear that laugh.
It's like
that's the situation they're in is
adults and Charles could see that coming
and he had all sorts of homicidal
fantasies about.
How about Robert?
It was unconsciously imitating when I
forced you draw comic books.
There's still a kind of sibling rivalry
going on between the me and the kids and
he was still living in
basically the wrong.
You're still competing with each other.
Drug products.
I still think of Charles approval
like Charles drawing come.
Yeah,
so what basically happened was Robert
got the world and Charles God,
his mother,
so they both won,
but I have Charles I don't think is very
happy with what he want
tunes
where we sat around and talked about.
I was usually the president,
vice president,
secretary and saying that he was the
trailer
to still.
He still resents the fact that we impose
on the role of supply.
Boy Them.
Excellent was the scapegoat and
five kids.
He was definitely the bottom of the
ocean to explain is that we have these
meetings for this,
this Columbus Club,
comics and Austin and bring out their
10th or different jobs or different like
a secretary and prison or vice president
on our
director Robert did or something that
seals.
The whole thing is just like incredible,
crazy,
similar thing in me and Charles and
Robert have been slight little room
upstairs in the whole rest of the world
to know what the fuck is going on,
so he's
working at it on the trees,
you know,
it was just together
in a closed situation
fired by the Disney movie where Robert
Newton plays alone.
John Silver in episode in 1955 when we
started like playing pirates here,
like normal kids go out,
pretend you've made this shift,
that little refrigerator cart and then
everything that Charles would walk
around town dressed up like long John
Silver,
crystal coded my mother's as Long Green
Code and he made himself a three pointer
and has that.
He had a crutch and you tied with leg
like go around town that way.
I hadn't realized that years later
fixated Charles really wasn't as
treasurer and then this thing done on
the native art played aren't as bad as
the first six or seven years after that.
We do these context about treasure.
I became Israel Baroque elaborate thing
way beyond the original Disney film.
This was one of,
Charles is one of our two med,
yes,
in which he would draw some of the
characters,
knives are also interact with each
other.
That was also a great school of
cartooning for me is having to come up
with clever retorts to him.
He was.
He's actually much cleaner and funnier
than I was.
It actually got kind of tiresome.
Buddy,
you know he had to do it,
but he was in charge.
Has very like definitely band from about
Charles was not.
Sometimes I think a lot of them do with
like overly morbid sensitivity to the
guy or something too as well.
Assistant you have a natural affinity to
get into your profit.
Off of robbery course was someone in the
middle man had this wind like
restricting and complex,
like terrible selfconsciousness
restriction and me as a kid,
I was like morbidly monster.
My body like sex plate completely came
time for me to become sexually like a
puberty or something like sex with
nowhere near my life.
You know what?
Just put them to sleep.
It was like six so heavily repressed,
which meant naturally editing.
Sneezers started to have a seizure,
so this was like a point where your
behavior becomes,
wow,
I have to get into the whole sector
versus normal up topic,
you know?
That's all I thought about when I was in
my late teens and early twenties in a
sentence and I masturbated about four or
five times a week.
How frequently did you ask anyone out?
My sexual desires.
You did.
Like I told him the other night.
I can't even get any reception know
whether it's the one thing or maybe it's
a combination of things.
Maybe it's a combination of the
medication and the lack of external
stimulation.
Maybe approaching old age to have
something meaning any,
some external stimulation to keep up
your interest?
I don't know.
Now that my sexual desires in that
earliest sexual abuse.
Have you ever actually,
it will be like 40 years old and getting
directions.
Here's my aunt or my older sister and
her legs and her shoes.
Like I need a table instead of going
like mother's closet and she had these
cowboy boots that she wore when it
rained and humping goes in the closet.
I
already
have
five or six.
I was sexually attracted to bugs bunny
bunny,
have to cover the chronic bucket to
carry the rail with my pocket to get
looked at,
periodically wrinkled up and handling it
so much that they asked me whether the
fire engine on the ironing board and
flatten it out,
and she did not as deeply as appointed
because it got old brown.
When she died.
It crumbled apart.
This sexual attraction to keep cartoon
characters.
You tell me
I don't change.
When I turned 12,
55,
56,
totally obsessed with she lives.
Went to bid.
Are they of best things I wanted to do
with sheep.
Now you see how how he conceptualizes
himself in relationship to her too,
so he's like this while he's a lot
smaller than she is and he's clearly
depended on her physical strength and
ability and so he definitely
conceptualized as himself as a
subordinate entities
very hung up on
even more so.
I think you were more shy
actually.
I think you were more afraid of women
was as a young person
in high school.
I had a few dates with girls when you
were in high school,
you at all with anybody sort of good
looking at everything.
Almost a handsome,
good looking chaplains and teenager.
There was just this.
Something was wrong with my personality.
High school was an absolute nightmare.
It was the most unpopular kid in high
school.
People were always taken on the the male
and the girls didn't have anything to do
with me.
They treated me like I was just there
trip by my by predominantly women
starting with high school where I
learned a lot about women because there
was this guy case Gutsche escape here
with like the
mean bully,
but he's also very charming and all the
girls liked him.
The dream boat that was also bullied in
my brother Charles was one of the guys
singled out for particular attention.
If you get this gang of flowing piece
that had around with disguise Ganache,
so scene where they were special punches
up my brother in the hallway at school
sense I to see Charles gave up trying to
be popular or had girlfriends or
anything.
If everybody saw that he could fight
back,
beat up by Scotch,
so that was probably enough to get his
depression going because it's a major
dominance,
hierarchy,
defeat,
and he was also an outcast,
so he's not even in the dominance
hierarchy.
He was one of the class of boys by his
own account that was so contemptible
that he wasn't even in the realm of
possible date partners for any of the
girls.
And so when you're thinking about why
Robert is dry drawing women with like
vicious bird heads,
one of the things that you might think
about is that for men at the bottom of
the dominance hierarchy or outside the
dominance hierarchy completely like
these guys were all they ever got from
girls,
including their own mother was rejection
like harsh rejection.
And it was enough basically.
Well it was really in the final
analysis.
It was enough to kill Charles.
Now I'm not blaming the girls,
but I'm trying to explain why Robert is
expressing himself the way that he's
expressing himself.
Why these images come up?
You
gotta take
tranquilizers.
That makes it a lot easier.
You know,
and so Charles still has this kind of
dream in the back of his head too,
which is really the image,
the idea that the Charles is living out,
which is that Charles has it much easier
and much better than he does because he
doesn't really have to deal with the
world and he can just stay at home and
comfort with his mother.
It's like he's not in comfort.
The guy he commits suicide six months
after this film
now
that's extremely interesting.
So young had this idea about
synchronicity,
you know,
he said now and then would happen in the
world that we're connected weirdly
because of a,
like an emotional contagion and it's a
very strange idea,
but I wanted to show you an example of
it because it's actually caught on film
here.
So when Charles and Robert are talking
about their mother,
you notice Charles Hunches right over
it,
right?
He's like even more inside than he
normally is and they turn into 2:13 year
old teenage boys talking upstairs so
their mother won't hear them as soon as
they mentioned her.
She pipes in.
Okay.
Now you see when,
when he did hear her,
she's complaining about the curtains
being closed with something in this
camera crew cluttering up your house,
which you know,
probably hasn't been cleaned since 1957.
It's not really that she matters that
she cares,
that they're there.
What she's doing is expressing her
dominance and it's.
And she does it in a very,
uh,
very subterranean way and Charles is
absolutely terrified of her.
No,
don't worry about it.
It's all going to be out here and I'll
be back to normal.
Cool.
These girls talking about one difference
could a date.
It's good.
She's envious.
They all are.
This is how I still
bitter about
it.
Most teenage boys are very cool and
aggressive and everything like that.
If girls would see that I was more kind
of insensitive things press,
but I expect that I could draw but
couldn't understand why they liked these
cool,
aggressive guys.
Not me because I was more kind and
sensitive and everything for them.
I was more like him,
but he realized he didn't want him to be
like them.
Basically filtered,
hurt and cruelly misunderstood because I
consider myself talented,
intelligent.
It's not very attractive physically.
I think those things really mattered.
It was what's inside.
When I was 13 and 14 and trying to be
normal teenager,
it was like a really ensured.
We just,
I tried to go.
Applicant thought they were acting.
It's raw and weird,
so then I just stopped completely and
just became a shadow and I wasn't even
there.
People weren't even aware that it was,
you know,
in,
in the same world they are in.
That kind of freed me completely because
it wasn't under those pressures to be
normal.
So I got interested in old time music
and went to the black section of town,
knocking on doors,
looking for old records and things like
that.
It would be unthinkable if you are going
to be a normal teenager.
So Robert can,
despite the fact that he grew up in a
family that was very difficult to escape
from,
did follow his creative interests,
you know,
and he,
he picked a path that was characteristic
of individuality and it did get 'em out.
You know,
he gave up on conformity.
But he found an alternative so you know,
it's pretty impressive and he did become
very,
very successful.
I want to show you,
I can't show you all of what I wanted to
show you today,
but I do
forced me to answer that door and take
her outside you to put this girl's
armored personality line.
Chileans,
Rogan,
and then you got a good grade on a test.
Then you've got the
fascinating.
There is six weeks
here.
His other guy got to light jobs,
hit you real art,
Nice.
Five years old at Christmas and this
whole thing happened during stack,
pleasantly collarbone.
Charles a pinching for getting in
trouble,
very diabolical as a Cuban.
And I finally would like beat him
unmercifully for these things that he
was always these crimes.
He was always convincing and it just,
it just made him worse.
I think the subconscious desire.
No,
just this.
Oh yeah.
Here we go.
Yeah.
I think we've got 10 minutes here.
So
they started being driven by that
session that I'll go down in history as
a great artist.
That will be my revenge because my image
celebrating Valentine's Day 13th,
1962 when I decided to reject
conforming,
when society rejected me,
I heard all that be yourselves to
myself.
Think I'm does not have to be satisfied
with cans and old records.
Girls are just utterly out reach.
They won't even let me draw them
all that change after you get a famous I
was used to
doing,
which was really quite sweet.
And then he did this one that was just
incredibly hostile to women,
very sexual hostile.
And I was,
I wasn't expecting it and it was really.
I was really shocked and taken aback and
really just kind of like,
it's hard for me to believe that he can
just channel in sales doing or work.
I like a lot of his work and certainly
this is the lyrical aspect of it.
But then I find me something completely
different reaction,
you know,
perhaps when I've been really turned off
and disgusted.
And um,
you know,
this,
this cartoon show blow is when I thought
about a lot of light.
On the one hand it's a satire of the 19
fifties.
The healthy facade of the American
family and it kind of exposes the
sickness under the surface,
but at the same time you sense the
crumbs getting off on it himself and
some other way and on another level it's
an orange sheets,
self indulgent orgy in a fantasy.
And the fantasy,
you know,
specifically this story is a story about
a father who commands his daughter to
give a blow job and she does.
Then they wind up having sex and the
little sort of leave it to beaver type
brother character comes running in and
he's the father and his sister and he's
shocked and upset.
He goes running to the mother and tell
her and mom comes out of the closet
wearing sort of snm kind of get up and
go,
oh cool.
You know,
and the next thing my mom is sending the
whole panel ends.
The whole cartoon is the parents saying,
gee,
we should spend more time with the kids.
You know,
so
you don't,
you read something like this.
And I think that it has gone over the
line from satire of a 19 fifties,
hygienic,
you know,
family and denial into something which
is just chrome producing pornography.
And I think this theme in his word is
omnipresent.
It's murder.
Been arrested,
juvenile position.
So the mother has these cute things
scattered everywhere.
We pulled it loose from each other for
the most part.
You spend all your time down here
watching television going across or
I spend most of my tops
so you can see how well they communicate
resources living in this.
Well you do,
you do most of the talking and the
relationship,
he said told me that you take those
medications.
Would you still feel nervous and
depressed sometimes?
You know,
not as.
Not as much as I would have been.
It wasn't taking.
What do you think would have just
stopped taking this stuff?
And I tried it a couple of times.
I didn't like what was starting to see
if I were becoming gradually on hinge
back on them again.
I tried a couple of times.
Do you still think they're picking my
brain?
No.
She doesn't have to clean up for the
cameras,
that's for sure.
Charles,
some people,
I mean some,
so you realize that this is a man who
spent like 30 years in his room upstairs
that has no friends and has never had
any friends and now it's his mother's
response,
five
from one extreme to the
streets and one of the last time you
slept old lady in the street and started
drilling or a better spiritual your life
and she just like got really frightened
and threaten to call the police and
everything.
Go to these strangers on the streets or
30,
but
that kind of stuff,
always got in trouble and everyone else
can be one good reason for leaving
illegal drug is
miserable
is true.
I saw all this
$200 ticket upstairs.
Ever.
See anybody
take a basketball once in six weeks.
I believe in a certain pride in yourself
for your answer.
Why not a ratio gets out of hand or
you're an EGOMANIAC?
Something in relation to them.
Yeah.
Your hygiene habits are pretty good.
Constipated,
15 more seconds.
Your
kids are always giving a success story
were real little.
I had to take care of your and giving us
all innovations that didn't work out.
We didn't meet
interested in legs and feet.
It's very difficult.
Well,
that gives you some indication of a
Freudian family.
It's not pretty good luck on the exam on
Thursday.
As you know already the.
There are lots of sample questions
posted on the net,
so it's all.
It's here right.